يبيعون كلاهم ولا يهمهم من سيشتريها حتى
انهم لا يعرفون كيف سيتعايشون مستقبلا
بكليه واحده
لكنهم يقررون بيعهم
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من عالم
غريب
هؤلاء اوصلهم الجوع والفقر للتضحيه بعضو
جسدي غايه في الاهميه
وجيوبهم مفرغه من الاموال فلم يجدوا مخرجا
من الفقر والعوز الا بالذهاب الى المستشفى
وبيع الكل
2500 دولار نحن نتحدث عن قريه
بالقرب من الحدود الايرانيه فهنا يقع سوق
كبير لبيع الكلى وشرائها من داخل
افغانستان
فهؤلاء الاشقاء الاربعه مثلا باع كل واحد
منهم احدى كليتيه املا في توفير احتياجات
استاذته وهذه الفتاه ذات 19 عاما باعت
كليتها لتسديد ديون زوجها
خلاص
الاف,500
لكن
10500 دولار مهلا هل كل ما شاهدناه يعد
قانوني
لكن هناك من يتبرع باعضائه لاحد اقاربه
مثلا ويخضع المتبرع والمتلقي لمراقبه صحيه
لكن في افغانستان فقط
اذان
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه المترديه التي عامه
البلاد بعد سيطره طالبان على الحكم فيها
احدثت ازمه انسانيه وطبيه واقتصاديه فيما
تحضر الامم المتحده من ان نصف الافغان
يواجهون خطر الجوع بعد فقدان العمله
المحليه لاكثر من ثلاثين بالمئه من قيمتها
امام الدولار